oh and it's Alexa Bliss running to the
counter following a prolonged absence
from the WWE Alexa Bliss has a serious
Life Update Alexa Bliss has gone through
a lot of different phases the latest
phase affecting Lexi Cabrera Alexa's
name outside the ring she opens up on
social media to reveal she was diagnosed
with skin cancer and now is in recovery
after having surgery we do beat up our
bodies you know on her Instagram story
Alexa writes dear younger me you should
have stayed out of tanning beds
according to the Mayo Clinic basil cell
carcinoma which was Alexis diagnosis
often follows long-term exposure to UV
radiation she ends her message all clear
now though thank you American Skin
Institute for taking great care of me it
really is a big group effort naturally
fans were worried on Twitter but Alexa
reassures them it was a quick and easy
procedure she adds this important
reminder glad I always get my skin
checked
WWE fans are very passionate and very
passionate about what goes on in our our
character lives as well as our personal
lives the 31 year old who married singer
Ryan Cabrera last year hasn't said if
the diagnosis led her to tapping out big
rice from Alexa that's Alexa in January
she hasn't been in the ring since but on
Wednesday we got some clarity
of you Superstar Alexa
Bliss yeah Alexa went Undercover on The
Masked Singer She was recently revealed
to be the voice behind axolotole
[Music]
when you're portraying a character you
can really push the boundaries and have
fun with it and that's what I've been
doing now WWE will always be home so as
Alexa takes a well-earned breather we're
just happy to see her in good health
doing what makes her happy this was
something that was personal for me
because I have actually crippling stage
fright when it comes to singing I wanted
to show like I can make myself proud and
like if anyone else is ever like having
something where they're afraid to do
something do something every day that
scares you because I did that today and
it was so fun
mic drop we love it
[Music]